honestly I can't believe I'm still alive
really five overdoses on life support
I've been stabbed a couple times be
overdose five times yeah what is that
experience like first time I thought I
got abducted by aliens
you've got a very personal story uh with
addiction and then you turned it into
this massive business opportunity
um actively doing this recovery process
and I'm changing from the inside out and
I start to get excited about it you're
addicted I'm addicted to it you got
sober you had a business when you sell
the business you're like you're not
going to work anymore here's what
actually happened I'll be raw and real I
fell apart I have more money than I've
ever even seen in my life and I'm not
[ __ ] happy the one thing that I
attribute by transformational experience
do is this one part of the process
there's this process that they call it
all right guys bang bang I've got Eric
here with me uh I thought a great place
to start is exactly why I started
following you on Instagram is I saw you
talking about addiction one day and I
was like oh all right let me you know go
learn more about this uh and in fact I
don't know that much about it right I
think I probably have like an obsessive
personality so I've always been uh
somebody who tries to avoid uh a lot of
vices because I'm like I probably would
end up in a bad place
um but you've got a very personal story
uh with addiction and then you turned it
into this massive business opportunity
um and so maybe just like where did this
all start or did you start getting
addicted to things when you were in high
school earlier or college like tell me
some of your story no no much earlier um
you know alcoholism and addiction is a
funny condition and I think that it
shows up in people in two ways one is I
do think that you can use and drink
yourself over an imaginary line that
you're never going to come back on the
other side of you see people that have a
normal relationship with alcohol and
then at some point in their life maybe
something happens and they're responsive
to that and they become an alcoholic
others I think are born that way and
that was me I've I've had addiction
since I was very little I did everything
in excess
and so you know I grew up in a town
called Salem New Hampshire it's about 35
minutes north of downtown Boston uh
suburb of Boston very blue collar
um my father was a logger he cut trees
down for a living my mom was generally a
stay-at-home mom kind of a crazy
childhood with you know a wild household
and two wild parents
um was it fun no no okay like I mean
like a bad Charlie I had a generally
decent shot well one year [ __ ] kid
you don't know can I swear yeah you
don't really know the difference right
like you could grow up in Iraq and bombs
are going off and that's your normal
right and so for me that was my normal
but it was loud it was crazy you know I
was around drugs alcohol in the
neighborhood and um
and
my parents got divorced when I was in
fifth grade and that was kind of like
this pivotal moment for me and I started
drinking and I started smoking pot and I
was 10 years old I've always had been
the kid with this lemonade stand and
fixing up bikes and making a buck
um and so that was the beginning of the
journey for me I started using drugs and
alcohol I also started selling drugs at
10. wait wait at 10 years old I'm
drinking alcohol and you were also
smoking weed doing crackling smoking 10
years old smoking weed I'm drinking
stolen beers out of the you know the
friend's parents uh refrigerators I'm
drinking wine I'm drinking Mad Dog 2020s
and I remember whatever you can get your
hands right but but yeah and then then
an older kid in the neighborhood
um
confronted me at first an ounce of weed
which turned into a quarter pound and I
think to this day as far as I know I
still I still have the state of New
Hampshire's record as the youngest
individual charged with a drug sales
really how old were you 10 years old
fifth grade you were 10 years old you
got arrested for selling drugs hand to
hand uh to a confidential informant
marijuana yeah so like so walk me
through what that looks like so uh
you're 10 years old an older guy in the
neighborhood that gives you some weed
and he's like go sell sellers come back
with the money you basically just get
the difference yeah I wanted I don't
know if you remember anyone that's old
enough to remember these are cool at
least up in the north at the time they
had jinko jeans remember jenko yeah yeah
my parents would never buy me any
[ __ ] jinko jeans I was like I'm
getting them jeans and so that's what
happened I started selling weed and uh
hustling to get things that I wanted
it progressed very quickly for me you
know alcohol weed turned to try and Coke
turn to trying pills turn to big on
ecstasy by the time I'm like 14
um but but at 10 years old you're
selling drugs and like walk me through
when you get arrested for the first time
because because to me it's just like
fascinating my parents experience yeah
you're selling drugs you said to a
confidential informant like is he like
yo are you 10 right like is it a shock
dude it was another kid that had got
busted by his parents his parents called
the cops and the cops had this other kid
wow set me up for real and so so I'm in
fifth grade my parents just got divorced
the bank just foreclosed on the home
that I grew up in I'm living in an
apartment building uh with my mom and
visiting with my dad at the time and I'm
on the bus and the bus pulls up to my
apartment building and there's like four
Cruisers out front and one of them is
has the dare you know the drug program
wrap on the on the car and I get I
remember getting out vividly off the bus
and walking off with my backpack and be
like Oh somebody [ __ ] up you know what
I mean like why are these guys here like
what's going on and I walk into my
apartment and there's like five cops my
weed my scale and I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
I'm pinched okay so from there once you
got arrested uh I'm assuming they take
you down to like the city or county uh
jail or whatever like they actually
didn't I was so young I don't think they
knew it was such an unprecedented event
that
um that they never actually put
handcuffs on me but I had to go to court
and I ended up getting a juvenile
probation officer I was on probation
like okay my entire childhood and was
that an accelerant like the fact that
there was you know because I think a lot
of people could be like hey uh law
enforcement intervened I'll put that in
air quotes because whatever they want to
call whether there's an arrest whether
probation whatever
oh let's get them back on track or you
almost like realize like hey it's not
that bad right and then you basically
just like let me go do worse bigger
badder things that's exactly what
happened okay and so you go from weed to
eventually you get to ecstasy and now
you're personally taking you're not just
selling but you're using all of the
above okay and what are your friends
doing are they into this stuff or they
just think you're like the crazy friend
that everyone has I hung out my friends
were like other kind of kids from broken
homes that
um had similar backgrounds similar types
of families and they were you know
getting in a lot of trouble uh you know
one of my best friends Frank got
arrested at 12 on a gun charge got
caught with the 22 caliber pistol
um you know we're fighting all the time
where it's it's a rough life it's a
rough life all right yep now how do you
get from like 1415 to eventually being
you know 18 20 years old where I would
consider Society at least says like hey
now you're a young adult right what is
that path like like are you just
continuing to use all the way up through
that okay
um you know I'm selling drugs
um using drugs I'm in that lifestyle you
know and to put a mental picture to it
I'm 10 years old on like a huffy bicycle
packing a BB gun with the Discman and
the headphones listening to like Dr Dre
The Chronic and Snoop Dogg and like
Tupac and Biggie like you're a gangster
just with a BB gun
like in the suburbs my dad's a logger
yeah yeah got it and so I don't know as
confusing as that is but
um how much uh impact did the music have
because a ton I don't know how old you
are but a lot of that I I talk about
that all the time I think the culture of
the of the music which today I talk
about
like our diet and the things that we
consume the content we consume the music
we listen to the books we read the
podcast the people we allow into our
Inner Circle all of that is so
exponentially influential and so coming
up in that gangster rap error like that
was cool you know what I mean like I I
think that's what I emulated he's a
white kid in New Hampshire yeah but I
think that was across the country I mean
even myself like the more that we listen
to it the like more bad [ __ ] we did
right and everyone's got kind of
different severity in terms of what bad
was for their area their friend group
whatever but I I also think at the same
time that the rap artists from the 1990s
into the 2000s ended up being some of
the best entrepreneurs of our lifetime
as well right and so in some way kind of
knowing that you ended up going and
starting businesses and really
understanding uh kind of the business
and investing world do you think in
hindsight that your experience in your
teenage years taught you a lot about
entrepreneurship and the ability to sell
things uh yeah mental toughness
perseverance
um
FIU muscles figure it out you know what
I mean
um you you get yourself in a lot of jams
on the street and so you constantly
survival adaptation like what's the
worst situation you got yourself in
I mean there's so many you know let me
walk you through a little bit of dude
I'm 14 15 years old and this is 1999
Oxycontin pharmaceutical grade heroin
being mismarketed by Purdue Pharma as a
non-addictive painkiller it's really
heroin in a pill is running rampant kid
that I grew up with down the street
comes over with a 40 milligram pill we
sniffed a thing I do half he does half I
get high in opiates that drug class of
like same thing as heroin for the first
time
um
and I Fall In Love out of all the drugs
I'd ever done I was like this is the one
like I'm like Superman on this [ __ ]
right and um and six months later I'm 15
years old I stopped going to high school
I drop out and I'm fully addicted to
Oxycontin and I'm in the process of
moving from Oxycontin to heroin okay and
at 15 years old in in my 15th year I I
finished it as a full-blown IV heroin
addict really yeah it dropped out of
school
hardcore junkie running the streets like
a like you know in a man's world and as
somebody who uh after surgeries I've had
to take uh some of these painkillers
right in pill form uh and I literally
I've told story before uh I took one of
the pills and I went uh I was in college
I went to class and I fell asleep like
the [ __ ] it just it didn't make me
addicted it just like I couldn't operate
on it right crushing them and snorting
them versus the actual just like IV
heroine what is the difference in terms
of like how your body reacted was the
heroin that much more addictive or did
you feel like it was actually pretty
similar in terms of crushing and
snorting versus it's pretty similar I
think that it's just a different
delivery system okay and so
um
crushing and snorting and uh you know
takes longer for your body to
to get the euphoric effects for it to
filter through your system and for it to
start to get in there it also isn't as
potent so you have to do more it's like
Amateur hour compared to the IV everyone
that's that ends up there if they stay
in the game long enough they end up IV
because what happens is you build a
tolerance and so I start off sniffing
one bag of heroin and it gets me high as
a kite but in a pretty short period of
time I can sniff 20 of them and that's
expensive but then I'm watching other
people because now I'm in the world and
I'm watching these people and their IV
users
and they are getting just as high off of
one or two bags as I am 20 because
they're shooting it and that's like a
economic uh evaluation of like I could
spend less money and get more high and
it's more intense it's it's about the
rush an IV when you use it and shoot it
it rushes you it hits you in seconds and
so that becomes a part of the thrill as
well and so you're 15 you're now full-on
heroin addict uh where are you living
are you still living at home
um my mom I was such a badass little kid
and my mom you know had her own issues
that after I spent two years with her
from 10 to 12
um she dropped me off at my dad's and
pretty much disengaged from my life okay
um and we we weren't seeing eye to eye
and so now I'm staying with my dad
um you know from
third maybe around 13 years old I spend
a year sleeping on a mattress in the
corner of a bedroom that he had rented
he saves up some money we're able to get
a small modest little ranch one story
house and we move into that together I
take up the basement you know sell a
dweller and kind of created my own
little drug Den World down there by the
time I was 14. does he know any of this
is going on or he just kind of doesn't
want to really I think he kinda knows he
doesn't know I'm constantly in trouble
right like I'm constantly getting
arrested you know when I was in school
I'm getting suspended all the time
the people at the school know who and
what I am the police know who and what I
am like and so but you know my dad is
like a lot of parents where he just
wanted to see the best in me and I think
that I think there's also this thing
that people think for young people like
that especially that like it's a rite of
passage or I'll outgrow it I don't know
that he knew the severity like I knew
that he probably knew that I drank
alcohol and smoked pot but you you fast
forward I I I shoot heroin for the first
time at 15. it's 17 years old I'm
working with him we're cutting trees
down it's a dog hot summer day in the
middle of New Hampshire in July
remember like it was yesterday and um my
dad had uh some heavy equipment that we
would work with and he had an excavator
he's running the excavator and I'm on
the chainsaw notching and back cutting
trees taking down trees and uh and I'm
dope sick when you don't have heroin you
go into withdrawals wow and so I'm sick
so I'm like you know sweating I got
sawdust all over me it's like you know
late morning and um I'm sneaking off and
like puking in the woods I mean life is
just miserable and I'm tired and I've
been doing this for two years now and I
think that I'm done and I remember just
putting the saw down and walking up and
jumping up on the track of the excavator
and telling them you know turn it off
and he kills him he's like what's up and
I look him right in his face and I'm
like Dad I need help really yeah and
he's like what do you mean I'm like I'm
addicted to heroin
what was his reaction he was floored his
eyes were this big I mean as a parent
you have to imagine that's like the most
terrifying [ __ ] thing in the world
your 17 year old baby yeah that you've
done your best with and he you know he's
a good dad and looks you in your face
until you tells you he's addicted to
heroin yeah I mean you go around the
world heroin acts don't exactly have a
great recovery rate and so
um we shut that down we we left the job
site we were back at the time we got on
the phone book went to the Yellow Pages
started calling through and and found
um some professionals to help detox me
off of heroin and that was really my
first solid attempt at trying to get
sober and so it was almost like he may
have known some bad stuff was going on
he didn't want to necessarily see it and
then when you said it to him it almost
sounds like you kind of smacked him in
the face and said hey I need help he
knew there was no doubt in anyone's mind
my friends were criminals
we partied we lived a fast life we made
money a fast way I think he knew all
that in a general but he didn't know
that I was like addicted to heroin he
probably thought I'd just party too much
and you know didn't have a whole lot of
regard for the law or a regular civilian
lifestyle when you go to detox what is
that experience like especially at 17.
that that one was out I've been to
plenty of inpatients because I was 17
and and a adolescent a minor that was
outpatient and so they actually gave me
the drugs and sent me home with them and
they just say here's some drugs to take
this will help you get off here's a
regiment to follow I get to go see him
every day and check in and they told me
what to take and you know they they
oversaw the process it took about a week
the problem with that a lot of people
get twisted with addiction
is they think that addiction is really
about heroin and they think that the
solution to addiction is sobriety
I thought that my dad thought that I'm
on heroin what's the very obvious answer
get off get off heroin you know what I
mean like but the problem is and this is
what I suffered from the from the next
five years almost
I would get off heroin
and I would get off all drugs and
alcohol and I would be so uncomfortable
in life I didn't know how to I didn't
know how to do anything interesting I
would be depressed anxious Restless
irritable discontent full of fear
paralyzed because you missed the drugs
or because you didn't know what else to
do because that's what addiction is
because people Totally Miss the mark on
what addiction is
heroin and Alcohol and Other Drugs are
some of the best forms of treatment for
the disease of addiction the disease of
addiction is an internal condition you
talk to any alcoholic or watch them and
they're in a state of sobriety
and you watch them crack a bottle and go
you could hear a noise and watch a
reaction it's this
you don't need relief from life right
now like you're having generally a good
day right yeah I'm here with you exactly
what's better but this guy he can't
stand he's an unbearable psychic mental
and spiritual pain until that alcohol
hits him until that bag of dope hits
them and so what happened to me was I
would intuitively with well-intentioned
people get told
you have to give up heroin and give up
drugs and alcohol and I would
in I would just be a complete disaster
and so over any period of time it would
get worse not better
and I would feel totally out of control
emotionally and mentally and then I
would eventually use and drink again to
gain emotional control and and take over
my emotions and and the heroin the drugs
allowed me to regulate my affect and
that's really addiction
and so the to fast forward that
the solution starts in abstinence it's a
prerequisite to getting better from
addiction but you must be in some sort
of recovery or personal development
process that will bring about an
internal transformation
a rearrangement of what's going on
inside of you
and so that's that's eventually what
happened there's a lot of story between
here and there yeah well um how old were
you when you eventually got sober I got
sober I was 21 years old it was about
two two months almost three months
before my 22nd birthday okay December
7th 2006. how many times do you think
you went in and out of any sort of rehab
or detox I tried to generalize it in
attempts to get sober times that I was
like this is it I'm done [ __ ] I'm all
in a hundred or more really constantly I
hated it so you you knew that you were
addicted and you wanted a solution but
you didn't know what what the actual
like sustainable struggled finding a
solution for five years I was constantly
like trying to storm the castle
and then just ugh and getting high or
drinking and going on another relapse
and when you look back now uh when you
did get sober what what ultimately like
that was the time that you got sober was
it not necessarily just like get off of
the drugs get off the alcohol but it was
replaced by something yeah let's talk
about it so the the events of that day
were very dramatic at this time you know
I'm 17 18 years old my dad tells me you
gotta leave
I can't help you no more right I'm bad I
spend the next few years out on the
street living like an animal December
6th the last day I ever used drugs of
2006.
um
there's a drug deal gone bad I pull a
kitchen knife
the other guy's trying to buy the drugs
I don't have any drugs I'm dope sick I'm
desperate and I Rob him with a kitchen
knife
and um he essentially calls the police
and and doesn't tell him it was a drug
deal but reports me for armed robbery
they swarmed the neighborhood I hide all
night I take I Rob him for 82 that was
that was my courageous so you you needed
drugs so bad you were so addicted that
you basically set up a fake drug deal
set up a fake drug deal to Rob him for
82 bucks that's what he had I took him
for 82 dollars and they bought four bags
of heroin with it and I hid in a closet
and that was the last time I ever used
drugs okay no it's December 6th of 2006
the next morning
I woke up
dude I'm like 197 pounds right now that
was 135 pounds I was emaciated I was
disowned by everybody that I know I
didn't have a friend left in the world
I'd run out of Lies I was tired they say
you have to hit rock bottom if that's
true that's exactly where I was I I knew
with a Moment of clarity that I was dead
or in prison if I didn't change now
and so I had been up in Portland Maine
for the last for those two years of
addiction I took off from there
um went down to New Hampshire
um reconnected with my mother who I
hadn't really had a relationship with in
some time and she let me
um sleep on a couch for a couple weeks
and what changed for me there was I
walked to 12-step meetings and a group
of unbelievable men that I will forever
be grateful for they were all like 20
something years older than me or more
that have been sober for considerable
time grabbed me up and sucked me in and
started to teach me how to live so the
cops never caught you for the armed
robbery
no
um
yes and no I ended up cleaning that up
and along with a bunch of other legal
stuff and I was like a year and a half
sober got it so it's one of these
situations where like you knew it was so
bad that it wasn't just the drugs and
alcohol too right like there was the
legal stuff there like it was so much
pressure it almost to me feels like
you're describe like the world is like
closing in on you 100 and you were like
I have nowhere left it is going to catch
me right it is going to engulf me if I
do not go and do something different
yeah and what is the 12 steps
like what is that group sure it
originated from Alcoholics Anonymous in
1935
um you know Alcoholics Anonymous a
fellowship that has meetings around the
world now of people that have found
sobriety
um and it you know the origination of
that group is that a New York
um stock broker named Bill Wilson
was struggling with alcoholism uh and he
was introduced to a religious movement
called the Oxford Group okay in the
early 1900s the Oxford Group was an
interesting group but they broke off
from the contemporary church basically
because they
were more they were more radical in in
kind of a born-again transformational
experience than a lot of the
contemporary church and in the Oxford
Group they had a six-step program of
spiritual action
and this guy Bill Wilson gets sober in
that he does this spiritual work it is
an inventory of your Character defects a
confession to the congregation
restitution to everyone that you've ever
harmed it's prayer and meditation it's
turning your will over to you know Jesus
Christ the lord and savior uh hardcore
Christian stuff
he gets sober in that
six months go by he's trying to take
this to other alcoholics to help them
alcoholic number two gets sober in Akron
Ohio uh from his help that guy was Dr
Bob a proctologist a drunk alcoholic
butt doctor in Akron Ohio
and in that
um that was the birth of Alcoholics
Anonymous okay and they went on to take
that program of action and develop AA
specifically for alcoholics and not just
mushroomed and exploded globally to help
alcoholics and drug addicts and now
there's more I think there's like more
than 215 12-step fellowships it's like a
12-step Fellowship for Wow every problem
you could have gambling anonymous uh sex
and love addicts anonymous Overeaters
Anonymous everyone everything yeah yeah
so as you're doing this how important
was it that the men who kind of took you
into their wing and really helped you
break the addiction that they were older
than you like I think a lot of times
um there's this weird dynamic where if
they'd been in the same age as you uh it
may not have had the same impact as
actually being older guys or no no I I
don't think so I think that then the
recovery movement wasn't as popular as
it is now we were at the infancy stages
of the nation's opioid epidemic you
young people weren't going through the
life cycle of opioid addiction and
treatment and finding recovery like they
have been for some time now now the
recovery scenes filled with young people
and helping other young people and it's
beautiful but it just happened to be
that at that time in that town these
guys were older than me they were great
mentors they were tough as [ __ ] on me I
mean they really were in what way
they they didn't spare my feelings at
all they loved me so much that they
literally did not give a rat's ass about
how I felt they'd tell me exactly what
they saw they would tell me exactly what
I need to do and be like you are a self
or self-centered dishonest son of a
[ __ ] and you need to change you know
and um they were right I was it was the
truth about me yeah then were you
offended when they were honest sometimes
yeah yeah would you do when they when
you were offended nothing yeah nothing
you probably sat there and I was
offended you know
it's fascinating because there's so many
people today that are afraid of
offending other people it's changed that
thing has changed the way treatment is
delivered and Recovery is delivered
explain it it's
what you're describing and how the world
has changed about people being uh scared
to offend other people and now you know
you're very limited in what you could
say like there's a lot of censorship
there's a lot of you know I don't know
lines in the sand a lot of that around
offending other people that now
now I think it's it's really hurt the
efficacy of the recovery movement and
treatment
um because they care about what people
think and they care about how they feel
and they care about offending them and
the problem is is that people like me by
the millions that come into these
systems we have broken operating systems
of how we think how we feel like it
should be offended that's a good thing
the very thing that we're offending is
the very thing that we need to smash and
disassemble and recreate
and so they end up walking on eggshells
around people it's become very difficult
I recently read David goggin's new book
never finished and uh in it he describes
the situation where he came from a
broken home uh really bad watched his
father beat his mother I mean just
everything that you know you hope that
uh kids don't grow up in that childhood
basically he experienced and in the
beginning of the book he describes it he
goes back uh to see his father after a
number of years and uh at one point uh
they go to a very late uh dinner his
father has like a skate rink basically
and after it's closed up they go to uh
Denny's and he said he's sitting there
and his dad's drunk and when his dad
drank that's when the bad [ __ ] came out
it's when the demons came out he
basically said I looked at this dude and
I was about to whoop his ass and he was
just like I was an adult now right and I
wanted him to suffer the same way that I
suffer the same way my brother and my
mother and all the stuff
and he says that there's something that
changes I think the way he describes it
is the weather changed in the booth
because his dad realized oh this dude
ain't playing right oh [ __ ] this ain't a
kid anymore right yeah and like and he
just saw it in his eyes and he said uh
basically they finished dinner in
silence he drove him back he grabbed his
keys and he left never talked to his dad
again and there was something in there
about
he wasn't necessarily uh explicitly
saying uh the truth or the or offending
him or anything but it's that still like
speaking to the core of the person right
and now in that situation he just did
with a look or whatever it was that he
was describing but also I think what
you're saying is like these men
basically told you the truth and the
truth is incredibly powerful it can be
incredibly offensive
but actually you described it as they
loved me so much that they told me the
truth yeah right they weren't doing it
because they wanted to hurt your
feelings or anything they wanted you to
get better they wanted you to be better
about me getting better and they cared
about my recovery and they cared about
my life far more than they cared about
how I felt yeah which is a powerful
thing super powerful and a pretty mature
thing for them to be able to see that
yeah totally because I think the ability
to uh offend people for the right
reasons actually brings it only comes
from a place of maturity right in some
weird way like there's people who are
arrogant [ __ ] right and they just go
around offending everyone and there's no
Rhyme or Reason and there shouldn't be
any reason for doing that nor should
Society basically tolerate that type of
nonsense yeah one of the things that
they would say frequently is that we
carry the truth with love interesting
the truth without they would say the
truth without love is cruelty but we
carry the truth with love I like that
yeah it makes sense right it's huge
because because what they did a really
good job with me and I was I was out of
my [ __ ] mind like like well I was on
I was a nightmare like I've been on the
streets a long time I've been surrounded
by violence I've been as much as you can
be in that life I've been in that life
and so you know I'm sitting there
staring at them and they're like telling
me the truth and in my mind I'm like I'm
gonna stab him with that [ __ ] pen and
like that's where I was at in the early
days and like they just courageously
were able to hold that space with me but
they did something really magical in the
beginning was they established rapport
with me
and I knew in my heart how much they
cared about me and that's why I stayed
and that's why I kept coming back
because I was like [ __ ] they're not
trying to hurt me like they're you know
I know they care about me it's like that
saying that um
how the hell's It Go that
they won't care how much you know until
they know how much you care they did
that very well with me interesting you
know and they spent time with me and
they picked me up and they brought me to
meetings and they brought me to Denny's
and you know they also caught me very
quickly one of the things they did was
got me involved in service work
you know hey kid go pick up the
cigarette butts
I'm just here because I don't want to
shoot heroin anymore what do cigarette
butts have to do with that and it got me
out of myself and it got me started to
acclimate me to a life of service
if you had like physically fought them
who would have won you think were they
were they physically bigger stronger
tougher there was a you know there was a
smorgasbord a really wide spread of
people I mean one of these guys was an
investment banker another one was an
attorney another one had done 25 years
in prison on a murder bid and got out
you know a long time ago and like
the the the slice of society that this
thing affects is everybody it's not
isolated to the tough guys the corporate
guys the the whatever it is and so do
you think it was a sense of respect that
you had for them like like inherently I
respected them I I think yeah I think a
lot about
um in high school I won the best behaved
kid and this is much similar to you uh
they knew who I was and they knew you
know all the nonsense that I was pulling
a lot of entrepreneurs have that in
common though right of course
um and I remember I walked into a
classroom and uh one of the teachers
said to us I went through you know this
is what the class is about whatever and
he just said we don't have behavior
problems in here or we don't have
discipline problems in here and he just
said it and I always thought to myself
like was it because it was a a adult
male saying it was it because he just
addressed it and he's just like like I
don't have time for that [ __ ] right yeah
but for whatever reason I wasn't a
single person there was a lot of badass
kids in this one class yeah no problems
right and I think about that because
it's like actually if if I'm honest
myself I think we respected them but
there was a level of like I don't want
to you would do dumb [ __ ] because then
that's going to cause you to have to
deal with the dumb [ __ ] and then I'm
gonna feel bad because I actually
respect you in some weird way and so
this sounds like a very similar thing
where you're like absolutely even if you
could physically have beat them up or
whatever and like kind of brought the
same street mentality to it out of
respect you were like oh maybe they do
have my best interest at heart and so
I'll go do what they're asking me to do
yep yeah it's fascinating
um all right so how do we get from uh
you're going through this like detox
process to eventually you actually start
businesses and and kind of figure out
how to create solutions for other people
one of the guys
um from recovery gives me a job in his
call center I start making a couple
bucks I um I get a 550 a month apartment
in a not so great neighborhood
um and I'm walking to work and I'm
walking to recovery meetings and I'm
hanging out on the recovery scene and
I'm I'm actively doing this recovery
process and doing the work that they're
putting in front of me
and I'm changing and and I'm changing
from the inside out and I like the more
I do the more I get and the more I get
the more I like it and I start to get
excited about it you're addicted I'm
addicted to it and um
and part of that excitement was I want
to tell everyone else about it and so I
lived in like the hood right and um and
right on like the outskirts of the hood
was this down and out state-funded
Treatment Center called Keystone Hall
and uh it was a rehab I never went to
but the place saved my life and I used
to walk from I would get out of work and
I would walk to the treatment center
right through the hood past the dope
dealers passed all the [ __ ] it head
down and I would get to the rehab and I
was so poor I didn't have any money they
would feed me
and I would just volunteer all my time
and I would spend it with our clients
and I would talk to them about recovery
and I tell them about my experience and
I tell them you know I've been here for
x amount of months I've been here for a
year it's working for me and I would
show them the work that I was shown and
I would start to take them through that
process
and
and in that I found what still to this
day I know to be my god-given purpose on
Earth was to help other people just like
me and in that
everything that I've been through since
I was little kids all the pain on the
street to all of it
it made it make sense and it gave it a
why
and it made it valuable and it made it
useful to other people
and in that I fell in love with it and
so after a little while at the call
center I left I went back me you know
after I've been sober a few months my
dad starts talking to me again I go back
working for him cutting down trees I
start saving money I'm doing side jobs
I'm with the guys at that facility I'm
at the recovery meetings I'm with the
recovery people and uh and you know I
save up some money my dad uh Believes In
Me at this point and when I'm about a
year and a half sober
um we put our coins together and come up
with about 50 Grand this is October
2008. okay this is you and your dad a
lot of great economical time October
2008 I buy with my dad's help I buy a
three family apartment building bank
owned foreclosed vacant for 150 Grand
and with this Vision that I'm gonna go
and live here and I'm gonna put a couple
beds in each bedroom of every apartment
and I'm gonna get those guys who are in
that 30-day rehab when they leave
they're gonna come here and live with me
and they're gonna pay me to stay in this
bed it's called a sober house and this
was a sober house before like I'd say
Sober House you kind of know what that
is this is 2008 like this is not popular
the guys in recovery that I was telling
I was going to do this like the [ __ ] are
you talking about so just so people
understand uh somebody is addicted to
whatever the uh Vice of choices they go
to the actual uh treatment center but
they're only there for some time boxed
amount so 30 days 60 days whatever it is
30 days usually okay so 30 days when
they leave the problem that you had
identified was they're gonna go right
back into the environment they're going
back to the environment that got them
there in the first place
entrepreneurship it's our problem and I
was like well [ __ ] I'm gonna fix the
problem I'm gonna give them a place to
go okay and then I provided structure
and so they would leave there and come
with me and we would I mean I lived with
them for two years that's how the
business started it was me in a
revolving door of 11 guys and I did the
recovery work with them we cooked
together we went to meetings together I
took them into the jails I took them
into other facilities to do service work
and help other people I mean we did
everything together and a lot of those
guys from that early day they're still
sober now I mean it was a long time ago
but more of the economics of it what
were they paying you like they pay me a
couple hundred bucks like 700 bucks a
month 700 bucks a month yeah and then
basically uh you were able to run this
and this is like your full-time job like
you're just no I'm going to work I'm
still cutting down trees every day
really so I'm waking up with these guys
waking them all up you know it's very
spiritual based and so we're you know
we're sitting in a circle we're doing
prayer we're doing meditation together
early in the morning
um we're reading out of you know
recovery literature spiritual literature
whatever and then they have jobs and so
they go to work I go to work after work
day ends we all meet back you know we're
doing family style dinners together we
every day was something different we're
going to recovery meeting we're going to
speak to new people at this facility a
jail whatever
and so and there were rules you know
what I mean you have to make your bed
you had to there was just a curfew there
was a lot of structure to it and so as
you're doing this when do you go from
okay I have this one facility to now I'm
going to like turn this into a business
um so 2008 2010
I'm you know being a logger is a
Bloodsport it is a tough way to make a
living and um what's so tough about it
you're outside all day long in New
Hampshire you know you get about three
months of decent weather and even that's
hot so you're cold hot in the snow
um you know you're cutting trees down
it's it's just hard physical labor all
day long you know 5 a.m wake up on the
job site by 6 30 6 45
you know the type of people that work
those jobs can be a little rough uh and
so you can't you know your employees are
you know problematic at times but uh
it's just always something you know and
and I just I really loved what I was
doing with that and every day I'd wake
up and be like
[ __ ] I mean I'm I got cut by
chainsaws I'm getting whipped by trees
I'm like it's just it's like I don't
want to do this anymore this is terrible
and um and I want to open a second house
and so at that time I went to my dad
tough conversation tough moment his only
son his only child and I go to him in
his business right his
I'm the Next Generation you know and uh
and told them I said that I can't do
this anymore I need to go full time with
this and that's when I made the pivot
and so did he wants you to take over the
logging business yeah yeah there's a lot
of pressure my whole life like since I
was little kids like you know when you
get up and run this business
and uh you know that type of thing but
and so it put a lot of pressure on
Having the courage to have that
conversation with my dad of like nah I
don't I want to do my own thing I want
to be scared terrified yeah
solemn you know he heard me he probably
saw her coming I was so passionate about
what I was doing you know and I was good
at it and so I opened the second one and
then I opened a bigger one
um and how are you financing those
oh it's crazy
this is one of my sticks about a lot of
entrepreneurs today coming out of this
economy that we've been in about
Investors and loans and debt and and
blah blah blah bro if people could time
travel back to 2008 9 10 even 11 you
could walk into a bank
and be like can I finance this bottle of
water and they'd be like are you [ __ ]
okay like do you know what's going on
outside get out of my bag like you
couldn't get a loan for anything right
yeah and so I bootstrapped that business
from that initial seed money to buy that
first building until I sold it La in
December of 2021
and I never took a single dollar of
investment money for growth and I never
took a single dollar of a loan or debt
into the business my waterfall didn't
have debt to pay down at the the
transaction right and the company sized
at that time we grew it we're doing you
know a little more than 50 million
dollars top line revenue
325 employees it was real business and
so what I did was this really
old-fashioned thing that's not very
popular it's called I worked hard and I
spent less
you know what I mean it takes [ __ ]
discipline though when you have money in
the bank and you're still buying cheap
food
and driving a shitty car and like not
spending living in a crap place that's
the discipline of like the
entrepreneurship mine was driven by the
economy which I'm grateful for uh but
that's what I did so as you're doing
this
what what did you kind of learn right in
terms of scaling this business because
300 employees is no joke uh also when
you start getting into tens of millions
of dollars of Revenue that that's real
responsibility and it's real risk
because now you could like really screw
things up right you can get yourself in
trouble pretty quickly you make a couple
bad decisions you buy a piece of real
estate that goes underwater you know all
these different things that start to
happen what would you say was like the
one or two things you did because you
had what I'll call like the street
education but that's big business now
now you're in a game of like you don't
just you know wake up one day and like
oh I didn't have to do real estate
transactions right you don't wake up one
day like why not a man's 300 people
right sure you may know how to sell
drugs on the street but that's a that's
a different skill set maybe a related
skill set but it's different was there
one or two things you did that you
really credit to like being able to
transition from just a pure Street
education actually being able to run a
business like this yeah I'm a 15 year
old Dropout that still doesn't have a
GED but what I do have is an
unbelievably developed ability to learn
I'm a sponge and so that's what I did I
just kept it glass glass half empty the
whole time and was constantly in this
obsessive pursuit of learning from
people learning from books learning from
anything and everywhere that I could
find information on
teaching myself things yeah how many of
the businesses in the recovery space are
run by previous addicts is that a lot a
lot of them a lot so like I'm assuming
that has a huge piece in you being able
to understand the problem really really
well and actually design what seems to
be one of the more Cutting Edge programs
to actually be able to help people
because I think the outcome here is not
just like Hey we're collecting rent
right the outcome is actually like no we
are helping people improve their lives
stay sober and kind of become that's
right highly functioning productive
members of society right yeah and so
like when you think about selling the
business why'd you sell it
from from opening day till transaction
day was 13 years two months and um you
know I started when I was 23 years old
and I think I was 35 right 35 when I
sold it
um and everything just has a life cycle
I I was in New Hampshire I didn't want
to be there anymore
um it was a tough I love it I still love
it I'm back in it you know a little more
than a year later here we are and uh but
it was just a tough business to be in it
was emotionally you know there's a lot
that happened there I I poured
everything that I had into that every
single day I had all my eggs in one
basket which is high risk
um and I was surrounded by death people
dying fentanyl happened fentanyl started
coming into America but 2012 2013.
what's going on with that stuff because
that seems like this the second coming
of the opioid crisis like it was opioids
uh and then it was fentanyl there's not
there hasn't been a real bag of heroin
on the streets in America in years what
does that mean heroin is inherent
there's no heroin addicts anymore they
don't sell heroin they sell fentanyl
fentanyl is randomly 50 to 100 times
more potent than heroin it you know
prior to fentanyl showing up in the
country
um
overdose death is like not that common
you don't like it's a once in a great
while that has normally through a
mixture of other drugs and stuff
fentanyl shows up and it just starts
killing people really and yeah and so
you know I look back and and you know
it's funny you asked me a question
earlier and you're like what was the
worst thing you've ever been through if
you isolate that to active addiction I
could answer it if you put it in my
lifespan it's Fentanyl and not that it
affected me directly from using it I've
never actually used it I've been sober
too long but it killed hundreds of my
friends thousands of my clients the
amount of death that I was surrounded by
really honestly [ __ ] me up and so I
mean there was
2013 14 15 16 17 18 I'm I'm showing up
to one two three funerals a week really
bro I'm concerned I've consoled hundreds
of grieving parents if not close to a
thousand I mean yeah like there's only
so many moms burying their 20 something
year old crying through your shirt that
like before it's like [ __ ] you know it
took a piece of me
um and so there was just all this
complexity of it I was tired there was a
business sense there was emotional there
was just time for the next chapter I've
been doing this a long time uh and so it
all came to to a perfect storm and I had
been ready I actually transacted four
times okay and so I sold minority uh on
three different bites into a family
office at a scaling valuation and then
myself to the same family office uh and
then to take chips off the table and
mitigate risk and have money you know
off to the side and then myself in that
family office divested out of it and had
a full sale uh when I sold in December
of 21. and I was still a majority owner
at that point as you're talking to
family offices or uh whoever ended up
purchasing the business
how much of uh who they're talking to is
like you the business person versus you
the guy from the street
the guy from the here's the funny thing
about recovery and the life experiences
I sit here and like openly you know with
however many people are going to watch
this talk about
all the stuff that most people would
probably have a lot of Shame about would
have a lot of regret would you know be
embarrassed and not willingly just put
out there but through the process that
I've been through
we say that we die the death of self
here and so like that guy's dead like I
go to bed at 10 p.m I'm up at five I'm a
dad to two boys like I take care of my
senior dad he lives with me up north
like I'm not I haven't been a street guy
in a very long time yeah you know and so
you know um Eric the business guy you
know it's still there of course but
America business guy Eric the Family Guy
Eric the friend Eric the guy that you
know has morals and values and
anything that had ever happened back in
the day has been Unthinkable for me for
a very long time like I don't think I
could even bring myself to do it because
that operating system has just been gone
for a very long time yeah one of the
most impressive parts of the business
that you build is uh you really built
two businesses right so you've got the
uh what I call the operating business
where you're actually servicing these
clients you're able to get them into a
better position in life and kind of make
them those productive citizens but
there's also a real estate component too
talk a little bit about the strategy as
you built the company and kind of why
you had the two different sides
um you know what's funny is a lot of it
I learned as I went but I always I owned
the real estate in the first sober house
I like owning real estate I believe
heavily in real estate it's an asset
class it's my most preferred asset class
I still own a lot of Real Estate
and so as I was growing I was purchasing
the real estate and fitting up the
facilities you know Eric the landlord
and the real estate holding company and
then leasing them back to the operating
company and starting these de novo
startups you know in those physical
plants and so I did that through you
know
probably
I don't know close to 20 sites wow
varying sizes right big small medium but
yep and why just stay in the recovery
space obviously
um there's a whole bunch of different
things in healthcare that uh you could
have gone into right but you stayed in
recovery just because you knew it and
you cared about it or with other reasons
it's you know to your to what you
recently asked me about Eric the street
guy is
Eric the recovery guy is different than
that and so it's my labor of love it's
my passion and so I'm not a guy in
recovery for an eating disorder or
Autism or a significant mental health
disorder I am a man in long-term
recovery from addiction and alcoholism
and so
it's it's just you know what I've been
passionate about for a long time and
what I know best yeah this your entire
story is like has this like emotional
component to it but also uh if you can
kind of separate out the emotional part
you look at it from a business
perspective what is unique is that you
were able to learn a number of the
things that you needed but also you had
great Market timing although you
probably didn't know I actually no I
actually did I almost started to say
that when you asked me why I sold and so
I apologize
after I checked all those boxes and I
had divested those three times in March
of 2021 I was tired and I was all of
those things but I was also looking
around in the world and going we're at
the top
so we'll forget about the sale I I was
actually talking about uh in the
beginning because of the headwinds of
the addiction a lot of it was timing
because there was uh immense explosion
of drug addiction but also there was the
incoming insurance coverage of
addictions you talk a little bit about
uh yes we know that the drug problem got
very bad kind of 2010 and and uh Beyond
but also talk a little bit about the
ability to switch from individuals
themselves having to pay to the
insurance companies now being obligated
to cover the addiction treatments
so Affordable Health Care Act Obamacare
comes out and prior to that health
insurance policies we're not required to
cover substance use disorder addiction
treatment or mental health treatment as
a required benefit and they had this
section of those policies that was
affected by a parity law excuse me one
sec
parody essentially said that we need to
stop treating addiction and mental
health disorders like their the little
you know annoying cousin of Health Care
that these are real diseases they need
to be treated and covered like real
diseases no different than diabetes and
so that law came out and it required
insurance companies to provide a benefit
for addiction treatment and that's when
the industry started to explode and I
just happened to be in a good position
because I'd already been there like I'd
been in the sober living since 2008 that
was 2011-12 I was already growing
um and so that happened
and then another significant thing was
um was the 2016 uh campaign that was
essentially run on addiction as a main
issue like Donald Swain Donald Trump
local politicians you know really
highlighted addiction
um and overdose death in those things as
a very important issue of their campaign
I mean my home state Donald Trump uh
called a drug and fist that New
Hampshire was a drug infested Den
beautiful place but drug infested Den
and so I'm in New Hampshire first in the
primary
um politicians are ramping up and that
you know the presidential Races they
start coming through 18 months ahead of
time two years ahead of time uh they're
already starting to you know testing
making sure that they got a good message
yeah and then you know the local
politician the governor and all that all
those races and so at that time I get I
get really a lot of of Tailwinds through
that and I kind of get inducted into
this political scene
um I I testify to the United States
Senate in 2015
um on the opioid epidemic I'm meeting
presidential candidates that are coming
through New Hampshire
um
front and center are you surprised like
do you ever like pinch yourself like I
can't I can't believe I'm testifying
right now yeah yeah yeah right yeah yeah
like if they had only seen me then right
well I you know what's funny is I walk
into you know this building in
Washington DC with United States
senators to give this three hours of
testimony and Q a with them on the issue
and I'm here I am looking you know Lamar
Alexander the older sitting Republican
senator from Tennessee uh and answering
his questions and telling him about how
I used to sell drugs and Rob people and
do heroin and I'm just like where what
is going what is my life you know what I
mean how did I get here
I I can imagine that that is uh one of
those moments where you're like it's
cool but also shocking if like if you'd
only told your younger self like one day
you'll testify in front of senators
about this yeah I mean and that's been
true of a lot of my life you know what I
mean like
people people often time are when they
learn my story or they kind of get a
gist of it they're taken back and
shocked and have questions and I'm like
I just like I don't know yeah I don't
know I don't know how I got here either
so I'm as confused as you you know at
what point did you start uh really like
leaning into Instagram because I think
part of what's fascinating you got this
like great story right and kind of
you've overcome so much adversity and uh
I think you're a couple years older than
me
I got a cell phone in high school I
think it was the first cell phone I ever
got
um
there's a lot of young kids who they
understand how to use this stuff better
than you know you and I understand
pretty good how to use it yeah but
there's like 18 year old kids running
around right now they literally don't
remember a life before a cell phone
right yeah no doubt and so like at what
point were you like you know what I need
to get on the internet forgot like I
need to like go build a person I
remember it
it's probably
2019 2020 ish somewhere in there and you
know I have an Instagram I probably have
about like 2 000 followers I got picked
a normal person like yeah I'm like a
normal guy on Instagram I got a couple
of friends yeah yeah I got I got
pictures of my dog you know I got
pictures of my kid you know I got normal
[ __ ] on there and um someone sends me uh
a clip from this guy Gary vaynerchuk
and at the time Gary was like going hard
in content on build a personal brand
attention and like that was his stick uh
at the time and I started watching it
and I'm like he's right
this guy is right and this could really
help a lot of people this could help
bring attention and mind you I was also
primed I've been being covered by the
media since 2008. I'm hanging out with
politicians
um talking to people in Trump's
administration of me and the governor
are frequently meeting and talking like
I'm in the paper I'm on the news I'm
getting called into this called into
that like I have attention real world
attention not social media attention so
I just had this thought I'm like
kind of all made it here and so he was
doing this thing called 4ds where you
pay and you go down to New York to
Hudson yards and there's 10 of you and
you sit in his office and meet a bunch
of his team and spend time with him and
learn about social media marketing and
that's what I did I went down to I knew
nothing about any of it and so
somewhere around the time period I went
down to Gary vaynerchuk's office met him
for the first time and and came out of
that and I was like this is something I
need to do yeah you remember how much uh
he was charging 10 grand ahead and yeah
so it's expensive but it's not
completely out of the realm for people
who have a business or yeah whatever
yeah good investment I I would do it
again yeah and when you're sitting in
that room like what at what point are
you like this could help me with my
business is it they could help me
personally like like what's going
through your head as to like why you're
like yeah I gotta do this
I it started to come into Focus for me
about
how attention was a commodity and how
that could just have General uplift to
anything that I do and that a personal
brand and and being known out there and
telling your story and being the first
and having eyeballs and all of that can
be beneficial to
whatever you know like I get messages
every single day of people that I've
never met I probably never will meet I
got one this morning guy told me to quit
drinking three weeks ago and I'm his
inspiration you know if I can do that by
post it on my story and putting out some
content and have a positive impact I
mean that in itself makes it worth it
let alone business opportunities drawn
attention to whatever it is that I'm
doing
um and you know so it's really worked
out for me it's also helped me Network
and socialize with amazing people sorry
about you that is how we met
um this morning you hit your snooze
button a couple times I saw it you said
and uh I I think it's important like you
have overcome so much you are so
disciplined you have been able to stay
sober for so long but like now uh
hitting the snooze button a couple times
it's not you know going and doing heroin
again that's right yeah but but there
are these like uh kind of
self-correcting mechanisms you were
talking about like look there's like a
discipline component to it how do you
think about your life and the structure
of it now especially like it almost
seems to some degree you got sober you
had a business you focused on that
business for you know 12 13 years when
you sell the business you're like you're
not going to work anymore right and
you're trying to figure out like what
else to do like talk a little bit about
that I fella here's what actually
happened I'll be raw and real I fell
apart really
dude well I'm up in New Hampshire you
know restaurants close at 8 30. you know
they're all the sidewalks up and um
and I sell my business and I have more
money than I've ever even seen in my
life and I I buy a house down here in
Miami
and I'm down here and I I got no reason
to wake up I have nowhere to be I don't
I'm not worried about making payroll I'm
not worried about sales I'm not worried
about I'm worried about nothing like
literally
and um and I ended up staying up late
and I ended up being out too much I mean
you know in Miami dinner oftentimes
starts at 11 12 o'clock at night that's
when the reservation's for you know what
I mean and so now I'm sleeping in and uh
and I had been disciplined
my entire journey in recovery I've been
incredibly disciplined and it was just
now that this you know being out of the
business relocating and spending a lot
of time down here
and you know I I put on weight I I um
and I just hit this thing and I was like
I'm [ __ ] miserable in the outside
world looking at me should be I bought a
Jet I bought a yacht I bought a killer
house in Miami I bought a Rolls-Royce
truck I bought I like oh my God how much
did you buy you bought a Jet a boat a
Rolls-Royce truck and a house is that it
or you got more [ __ ] I'm sure I got more
[ __ ] but that's the big stuff and like
and I'm sitting here and I'm like I can
go anywhere I want and do anything I
want and you know
I'm not [ __ ] happy yeah I'm not happy
and it just hit me and I was like uh it
was the [ __ ] one of the most profound
life lessons that I've been through in
more modern times of course was like I'm
a guy that I don't give a [ __ ] if you
give me a billion dollars right now I'd
be up at 5am tomorrow I gotta get up and
make the donuts every day that's what I
do I'm a grinder I love the process I
love doing you know I love building I
love the discipline I love the structure
that's also what I talked about on my
story this morning was like why do we do
things for the effect produced
and the analysis is you know you drink
because you like how that feels you do
drugs because you like how that feels
but you also have to tie that too do you
like the result
and so I live a very structured
disciplined life I'm up at 5am I get an
early morning you know for me it's
prayer it's meditation it's reading it's
you know contemplation it's
manifestation and and I'm normally out
the door for the gym by like 5 45 ish
and I get my workout in the world is
quiet my phone is quiet and I get my
workout in a comeback a shower I eat my
first meal for the day diet very
important uh and by like about 7 30 in
the morning like I'm ready for the world
and like some of them haven't even woken
up yet I beat them you know I [ __ ] with
them all the time I'm like I'm so much
richer than you how the [ __ ] am I up
earlier than you are
but there is a mentality it's like one
of the things uh my wife and I talk a
lot about is like there's the easy life
and then there's like a hard life yeah
and
a lot of people
are grinding their asses off to get to
the easy life and so many of our friends
have been fortunate to get some version
of that some of them more so than others
or whatever once they get a taste of the
easy life there's a fork in the road
some of them double triple quadruple
down on the easy life they say you know
they're like I'm retired I'm chilling
but you know what I want the the easiest
cake job possible whatever and some of
them are like yo I miss the hard life I
need the hard I need the difficulty I
need the edge I need the things that
keep me going do you know that my
investment banker and my m a legal team
and my tax advisors and all this group
of like insanely expensive Advisory
Group that surrounded me through these
processes
we're like You're Gonna Miss This and I
was like
I don't really think I am like I don't I
don't know about that you give me 100
million dollars and like I'm gonna be
just fine don't you worry about me and
they were right you know what I mean
like the discipline the grind the stress
The Hunt The Kill the the build the
camaraderie the team the mission all of
it and now you know I'm happy I'm back
in it I'm back in it I got problems all
day long and I'm grateful for them yeah
what are your goals now
you really want to know yeah
um I don't want this to sound to come
off the wrong way and and I I need to
explain the why behind it for people to
to me for me to feel understood but I'm
working on a net worth of a billion
dollars okay I don't think that's a
crazy idea I don't think it's a crazy
idea either right small Club
not because I I just told you I have a
plane I have I have a jet I have a boat
I have a house like I have like if I
have more money I don't even know what I
would do with it to be frank with you
um so it's not for that right and I
already told you I got to get up in the
morning it's not gonna change my life
I'm not gonna do anything differently
because I am a fully tattooed
former criminal drug addict 15 year old
10th grade Dropout without a [ __ ] GED
and I want to be the first one to do
that
and not for me because I want to show
them it can be done if I can get there
what can you do you know if I can
achieve this if I hit that goal over the
next 15 20 years
then what's possible for the rest of you
and frankly I don't want to say it's
going to become easier over time but
they're gonna have more tools that they
can leverage right people don't people
underestimate that you know guys in our
age bracket like we had it a lot harder
in the early days of Entrepreneurship I
started my business I didn't even have a
MySpace
think about that yeah the internet was
not the internet you still went to the
library and checked out books and read
them you know you went and sat in the
seats at Barnes Noble if you couldn't
afford them and rent them and put them
back and and so access to information
access to creating businesses and
opportunities
it's insane these days yeah I think a
lot about like the new technology uh
solves problems that other people
previously had but it creates new
problems as well right so one of the
things that's fascinating to me about
your story is you're dealing with these
addictions that in 2005 let's say many
people especially the insurance
companies did not look at drug addiction
or others as these Health Care problems
they looked at it maybe in other ways
they didn't want to cover or or what
have you
today I actually think of digital
addiction as similar to what 2005 was
for drug or alcoholism right and and one
of the things that last year uh I've
told story before somebody handed me a
physical book and I tried to read and I
couldn't read it and not because I can't
read I thankfully had you know enough
education to read I could
I could trade I I could not sit with the
physical book and not reach for my phone
every 30 seconds and I was like this is
bad and so I told a friend that kind of
offhand comment at dinner one night and
he goes get your phone out all right he
goes look to see how many times your
phone lights up and so on that uh iPhone
you can see on my notifications and
stuff it's
750 something notifications every single
day
and I just looked down and he's like
dude literally every time that thing
lights up he goes whether you realize it
or not if you see it out of the corner
of your eye if it's sitting next to your
desk while you're working or reading or
whatever he's like you're looking right
and he's like and so shut that show as
busy as us if it doesn't go off for 20
minutes you're like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this thing
something in the world happened right
yeah and so uh what's interesting is
like yes the internet and social media
and all these things they solve all
these problems and it's amazing and they
provide all these uh different things
but now let's introduce new problems
where now I look and I see a lot of
these young Founders dude they spend
more time on [ __ ] Twitter or
Instagram than they do building their
business we've seen it in the patient
population and treatment of how they've
changed so much so I have a couple
things that I really want to tell you
about okay
um one is is information that needs that
most people should know if they're
concerned with addiction it's it [ __ ]
blew my mind
a lot of how we think about addiction is
based out of this early experiment in in
the 80s and the early 90s where they
took a lab science box and they put a
rat in it it's like a little rat cage
and they put two bottles of drinking
water and they had regular water and
then they had drug infused water they
ran the experiment with heroin and they
ran the experiment with cocaine
in that experiment what happens is is
the rat tries both he feels the euphoric
effects of the drugs
he goes back to the drugs he continues
to use the drugs he becomes physically
addicted
and almost most of those Rats end up
overdosing and dying
the that that is in Psychology textbooks
for people that are our health care and
mental health providers and you know for
doctors and nurses and folks they don't
give a lot of educational addiction and
so the philosophy out of that is drugs
are bad
they have chemical hooks if you do drugs
that they're going to get you and you're
going to become this like this addicted
rat
out of that
philosophy is also the prohibition
mindset the War on Drugs we have to
eradicate the problem we eradicate the
substance follow um
this guy a social scientist up in
Vancouver Canada he's an old man now his
name is Bruce Alexander he wrote a book
um called the globalization of addiction
it's unbelievable and he ties addiction
to to economy uh and western
civilization
and he comes around and says well wait a
minute
we've we've isolated the rat and he
starts an experiment called rat Park and
he builds a rat cage that's 10 feet long
and eight feet wide or some [ __ ] it's
huge and he puts wood chips and aluminum
cans and you know wheels and rat food
and you know shiny [ __ ] and toys and
tunnels and he and he puts a bunch of
rats in there
male rats female rats they're having sex
they're rat pops they're they're doing
what they're meant to be doing in the
best possible environment that Iraq
could want to say it sounds like awesome
exactly awesome yeah and and the guy
built on tunnels listen he comes in and
he introduces drinking water and he
introduces heroin water
the rats out of curiosity try both
they watch over time the rats favor the
drinking water and they occasionally use
the drugged water and get intoxicated
because rats like the party every once
in a while no rats become physically
addicted to the heroin unlike every rat
in the isolated box wow
not only that he takes isolated rats he
gets them addicted to heroin and and
then he removes them
and he puts them into rat Park
now modern day Western Civilization
thinking and philosophy around drugs is
in Rat Park if the drugs are available
we gotta eradicate them all these brats
are going to become Junkies
it also will tell us most people would
jump to a conclusion that this
physically addicted addict junky rat
entering a productive healthy rat
Society
is gonna with access to drugs is going
to be a menace to society and continue
to use the drugs the rat is aware
there's drinking water and there's drug
water it is physically addicted to
opiates it is going to experience
painful withdrawal symptoms if it does
not use that drugs drugs and it knows it
and it knows it's available it kicks The
Habit almost every time no rats become
addicted and no rats overdose and die in
Rat Park
because what the one context of the
study of addiction and the treatment of
addiction and solutions for this
is that has been evaded entirely's
environment
because if we look at environment all of
a sudden we have to take [ __ ]
responsibility
it's genetics it's trauma it's you know
the substance it's the bad neighborhood
it's it's all of these things that we
place the blame on
so out of this he he births this thing
called the dislocation theory of
addiction
and essentially if you look at at slices
of generations over time I think
everyone would agree that Society from
addiction and mental health standpoint
is getting worse generation over
generation in in decade blocks the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s 2000 no 2020s like we're
[ __ ] worse now than we were 10 years
ago 10 years ago was worse than it was
10 years before that what's happening
our society is becoming more and more
dislocated digital devices are enormous
and so when you take when you think
about what a human being is what are we
strip away all this [ __ ]
we're a pack tribal mental animal and so
we have a basic necessity for human
connection
for bonds we have uh we need a life that
has hope and so all of these things in
the way that we're living and continue
to live and it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy has continued to create an
elevated stress response on human beings
that Bruce Alexander would describe
substance use problems as a maladaptive
response to an overwhelming stress uh
stress condition
it's phenomenally interesting you know
why it doesn't blow up why
how does Pharma make money on that how
do you profit on that you have to
disassemble things
there's no way to make money
follow and so when you look at the magic
of the recovery Community recovery
Community essentially you look at what I
learned this and it like blew my mind
and I was like
I got sober and I met these men and like
they became my tribe they became my rat
Park they were the [ __ ] connections
they were the people you look at so many
of these different things that that
about the world that we live in the
middle class you know either a Democrat
you think it's the [ __ ] rich people's
fault or rich people you think they take
all our money whatever it is but the
fact is is the hope of a young person
today is getting less and less my
grandfather uh in 1952 bought a modest
small uh single story home on two acres
of land and he had a wife that was a
stay-at-home mom and he raised three
boys
he was a steel worker in a mill
he owned two acres of land in a home and
had a stay-at-home wife you can't even
be a [ __ ] construction worker and
have an apartment let alone have a
girlfriend you gotta feed her you know
and so growing up in in this environment
it's just tougher and tougher and
tougher for people the future is Bleak
for them you think about in in in the
game in The Game of Life what we're told
okay we grow up we're either have or
have not if you're not wildly successful
you're going to get a job you're going
to go there for 40 45 years
you're gonna you know hopefully get a
job and get a better job and then get a
better job most of your money is going
to pay your bills you're gonna have a
[ __ ] life that you can't stand so
much that hopefully you get two three
four weeks of vacation and can afford to
get on a plane and go somewhere nice as
the highlight reel to your existence and
then at the end of that what happens you
get a [ __ ] retirement and a pension
you get fixed income and what do we do
to our elderly
we're all facing that road if you live
long enough like you're going to end up
with some kids that [ __ ] visit you in
some facility playing chess with some
other [ __ ] and like it's just a
future for most people is not bright and
so when you think about that like of
course they're using [ __ ] drugs of
course it's getting worse when you talk
about environment what it immediately
makes you think of is uh the book uh
being mortal by a tool gawandi uh he
talks specifically about old age death
and one of the
um Assisted Living centers
um realized if we put live plants not
fake plants not no plants actual real
living plants around the center in
people's rooms they live longer they're
happier they have a kind of a better
quality of life yeah if you surround
people with life
they end up actually thriving absolutely
and it's so fascinating because it also
parlays perfectly into James clear's
entire idea of like if you change your
identity it changes your habits so if
you tell people I don't drink you're not
gonna drink right but if you just say oh
you know what I'm gonna have the uh
personal will to just say now I'm good
on the drink tonight right you have to
actually start to identify it right I'm
somebody who goes to the gym
now you start to go to the gym right
like if you can make it your identity
into your point if you're part of the
recovery Community right if you're one
of the rats in that Park and you're like
no this is what we do
then you're good even if you do like the
party every once in a while you're still
able to majority of the time stay where
you need to be it's very powerful the
problem it is very powerful and and when
you think about the problem the
frustrating thing that that has been a
problem that's been persevering in front
of me that
that bothers me is
we figured out for the ones that make it
out that are able to ask for help
we know how to get them well you give me
you call me tomorrow and say someone I
care about as addiction or alcoholism I
have a solution for you I know how to
help them they have to do the work
but they can get better and recover
what what nothing is being done about is
disassembling the machine that's
creating them
and so you know which is getting worse
day over day year over year
you know
when you look back at the last 20 years
of your life what's the biggest surprise
to you
honestly yeah I can't believe I'm still
alive really yeah when I was 15 years
old I used to like openly talk about
like yeah I'm probably not gonna live
fast like
21.
I used to live like that you know five
overdoses on life support I've been
stabbed a couple times and my head split
open by a crowbar I've walked away back
up back to Austin you overdose five
times yeah
what is that experience like
I thought the first time I thought I got
abducted by aliens
I did yeah you know I'm in the backseat
of a car with some you know
some homeless couple driving around and
I just copped a bunch of heroin for
everyone and you know I mixed stuff up
in a needle and I shoot the stuff up in
a car
and that's all I know and then I come
too and I got these big you know Square
Hospital lights above me and I'm on a
cold Gurney and and um and you know
masks and lights and everything and um
is really confusing uh waking up to that
yeah does it get easier like by the
third fourth fifth one do you like know
what's happening or is it still kind of
by the third fourth fifth one I'm so
[ __ ] miserable in my life that I wake
up and I'm pissed off that they [ __ ]
brought me back
wow I'm like [ __ ] this would have been
just fine you know I would have been
fine and you know checking out today
that would have been all right how'd you
get stabbed
putting around the hood doing drugs
selling drugs getting abused with people
you know yeah yeah did you uh this is a
weird question but one of the things
about
um whether it's uh projects or certain
communities
did you ever get stabbed by someone and
then friends with them afterwards
or was it nah [ __ ] you you stabbed me
and don't let me see you in the street
yeah yeah got it
um you know but I did here's an
interesting thing
to your point
um nobody has stabbed me because I don't
really know those people all that well
um we didn't even speak the same
language so they communicate very well
and and now you know I look back and
take responsibility I was in a
neighborhood that I shouldn't have been
in doing [ __ ] that I shouldn't have been
doing and trying to get away with things
in a game that I shouldn't have been
trying to get away with and so like
increasing the odds I knew the risks you
know what I mean I might get stabbed but
[ __ ] it you know you weren't walking
down Park Avenue it's part of getting
better this is this is this is I don't
know if you asked me this question but I
feel like you asked me something like
this
the most powerful experience or the one
thing that I attribute Tran my
transformational experience do is this
one part of the process okay and there's
a lot of work you have to do to get to
it to get you ready for it and have a
shift in thinking and a shift in feeling
and emotions and thoughts
but it's this process that they call
amends
and so I sat down with these men and
they were like Eric if you want to
obtain lifelong sobriety and if you want
to have this transformational experience
you need to do what we did and we went
through this process of immense and what
that was was I made a list of everyone
that I had ever harmed
ever
I didn't get to judge how big or small
the harm was if it was a yes or no
question did you harm them yes or no yes
they go on the list
and then the rules were this were that
if I could make an amends to them
as long as it didn't hurt them or
someone else I had to make it
personal consequence meant nothing
I had to put myself In Harm's Way to
accomplish this
and and then how you made it was also
very structured and they're very
disciplined about this you never say
you're sorry your whole [ __ ] life
you've been sorry if people applied what
you did to the word sorry all sorry
would mean was [ __ ] I got caught I'm
gonna do it again
so we don't say sorry in this process
people think it's like you go around
apologizing we don't apologize you might
Express regret and so what we would do
is I would go in
in these different situations of people
and places
and I would say you know I'm a drug
addict
but and um and I harmed you and how I've
identified that I've harmed you is I've
stole from you I assaulted you I cheated
on you I whatever
and I'm willing to do absolutely
anything I can to make that right
foreign
did I leave anything out is there
anything that I've harmed you with that
I'm unaware of and you shut up and you
let them talk sometimes they're like no
sometimes two hours of operating you
goes by and then um and then the next
question is what what can I do to make
this right and whatever they tell you to
do you do
there are 300 people almost on my list
I made amends to
put people that I was involved in
violence with I made amends to stores
that I robbed I made amends
I mean if you can think of it I I went
and cleaned up all of it what's the
craziest thing someone asked you to do
say that again what's the craziest thing
someone asked you to do it to make
amends to them oh god
um I was talking about this the other
day uh I made I used to steal from
Walmart I treated that place like a
personal ATM right and um Sam Walton
wasn't happy with you no no he's pissed
um and so I went into the Walmart and um
and and I asked to speak to the manager
and
and they waited around and the manager
came up I went through my spiels my
name's Eric I'm a drug addict I want if
you don't know them you say I'm on a
life and death mission of recovery my
life depends upon being here today I've
wronged your store how I wronged your
stories I stole from here by the best
count I probably stole 57 flat screen
TVs you know a hundred or more [ __ ]
electric toothbrushes Enfamil by the I
mean like do we used to run in there and
put when flat screens actually cost
something back then we'd stack up the
the flat roll away and um and roll it
through the front door and we would know
loss prevention was going to come and
you know sometimes would be sneaky and
get away with the [ __ ] but sometimes
they'd roll out and they'd be like
they'd always say the same [ __ ] you know
what they say when you're stealing what
excuse me sir that's what we called it
you get excuse me sir and uh they go
excuse me sir and be like back the [ __ ]
up I'm [ __ ] you know and just act
crazy and they'd be like oh you know I
make 17 an hour take it yeah and don't
have a gun yeah exactly and so
um so I tell the manager this and this
is a longer version uh than the story I
told the other day this is what actually
happened and like long face like
and she's like uh
I'm gonna have to get lost prevention
wait right here I was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm like I'm going to jail this is like
my third amend I've ever made I'm brand
new right and they told me Walmart would
be an easy one I'm like this is not easy
and
um and so the guy comes out and he
happens to be like a higher up and loss
prevention and I go through the process
with him and he says give me your
information and I'm like all right and
I'm like I'm going to jail like they're
gonna prosecute me for this and a couple
days later he calls me up and says Eric
listen
we get a real problem with addiction
down here at Walmart and uh we got a
real problem a lot of people stealing
and we'd appreciate it if you come in
and meet with us and and help us out
figure out what the hell what the hell
these addicts are doing to Rob Us blind
and so I went down I went to
occasionally they would call when they
wanted me to they would call me and I
would go into these trainings and I
would teach them all the scams
of how we robbed Walmart it's crazy
right I mean we used to go in and take
like those electric razors that cost
like a hundred two hundred dollars or
electric toothbrushes and I would get
like one of each or a couple of them and
and I would have like a Walmart bag and
I would just put them in the bag and I
would walk to the return desk and return
them and get gift cards and then sell
the gift cards for 50 cents on the
dollar
and it's like ding ding ding it was like
15 minutes I'd have the guy that was
buying the gift cards in the [ __ ]
parking lot waiting for me go up hit him
the gift card he has 300 give me a buck
50 cool I'm out
it's crazy and so that was one another
what was their reaction when you're
telling them like things like that right
which are like they're like you do what
yeah yeah they're like stupid they're
like but they're still like damn 150 300
not like this add something quick every
day yeah you know what I mean like yeah
I can't go to that Walmart I've been
there four times this month you know
drive me two hours to some other Walmart
and uh it's crazy bro Home Depot same
thing but um I'd have those little
faucets you know the expensive you know
thing those things like 500 bucks a
thousand bucks I'd walk it right up
return it and uh and they would just do
it because they'd say give you store
credit gift cards yeah yeah they give
you store credit card and have a nice
day and you know yeah and sell those to
all the contractors the Home Depot card
so they're getting 50 cents on the
dollar money they love you yeah they
love me and um and another time uh
when I did all this that overdosing and
uh four of those overdoses I ended up in
the same emergency room wow Parkland
Medical Center and like I would like
overdose like 30 minutes away and like
somehow they brought me to this [ __ ]
place I drove past five hospitals to get
here and um and I was you know I was not
pleasant like when I thought I got
abducted by aliens that first time I
woke up I was naked they had cut my
clothes off of me I felt a cold hand
grabbed me to stuff a catheter in me
they're holding me down and I jumped up
punched a male nurse started running
around they sedated me put me out I woke
up like two days later every time I
would come to down there I'd cause a
scene one time I'm running around the
nurse's station in the emergency room
with a Johnny wide open naked they're
chasing me um you know just crazy [ __ ]
and um I am made every single time they
were like please don't leave I'm like a
[ __ ] out see ya ripping IV lines out
of my arm and bouncing out of the
hospital going to get high and um
powerlessness just can't not
and so I walk into that emergency room
this is a powerful one and um
and I I asked to speak to whoever runs
the emergency room I'd like the little
triage desk
and um
and they I gotta sit there for like
three hours of course of course and this
woman comes out and says can I help you
I said yeah can we talk somewhere
privately and we walk through the
hospital we go to this conference room
and we sit down and she's like what can
I help you with and I start telling her
the story I say Hey listen you know a
few years ago I'm a drug addict I'm in
recovery I harmed your facility here at
your hospital and a few years ago
um there's a span of uh like six months
and I ended up in here like four times
on overdoses
and she's looking at me and I start
telling I said you know this was one
time that I came through and I punched
nurses this other time
she starts [ __ ] crying she starts
crying she starts crying
and I'm like okay like this isn't going
as expected you know what I mean to me
it's business as usual like like I've
done this 242 times already yeah exactly
and um
and
Eric
I remember you
wow
and
um
and you came in here so much and you
were so dramatic with your stays and
then we never saw you again honestly we
thought you were dead
we talked about you we still talk about
you occasionally wondering what happened
to you
and um and she's crying I start crying
and she says something that [ __ ] hits
me like a like a Mike Tyson punch you
says
we never see people like you get well
and I was like
and um and I said what can I do you know
what crime we're hugging you know we're
having a moment I said what can I do to
make this right she says I'd like to
leave your number at the nurse's station
and when we get addicts here that come
here we see them all the time that
overdose they don't listen to us they're
just some nurses
would you come speak to them I said
absolutely and over years I probably saw
I don't know 150 200 people bedside in
that emergency room they'd call me two
in the morning two in the afternoon Eric
we got one down here will you come talk
to him and true to my word you know I'd
go down there and sit next to them and
help a lot of people get sober out of
that emergency room you know not
everyone listened but got a few of them
and so just very powerful powerful
experiences like that most of them
didn't it didn't work out the way that I
thought they were going to you know I
had one where
it's kind of a crazy story
um
where there you know I've been up
shooting cocaine for like three days
right you start losing your mind after a
couple days being up doing cocaine and
we had heard these dudes that we knew
had robbed uh mini golf place and they
robbed the safe
and um
and you know they robbed the safe and I
was with a couple Bad Dudes and we were
we thought we were battering those dudes
and so we were like well they were off
safe they got the money let's Rob them
so that's what we did and so followed
the money yeah we set them up we we went
to someone that knew him and they they
said come over and they came in and it's
a long story but what ended up happening
was we robbed them one of them had a
handgun that we didn't know about my
friend got shot I got shot at
um dumped a clip trying to catch me uh
coming out of this house
my friend got shot in the chest through
here my other friend got shot through
his hand
and um
and they took off and everyone dispersed
and uh and it was this crazy situation
getting you know
and so in my head I'm like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this kid this
is like you're gonna shoot at me trying
to kill me and uh that was the first
time you shot it no
um
but in that situation I'm like it's on
right and now I got filled with anger
I'm filled with hate he ends up getting
pinched because some of the other people
telling him he goes to prison for six
years for this
wow that kid I put him and listen my
this is the shift in perspective of old
self is dead new self is different a
totally different perspective at the
time we on the street you shot him you
tried to kill me [ __ ] you
I go through this recovery process and I
start to wake up to some truth around it
and I said
this guy was you know in the same life
that I was but I placed them in a
position where he needed to defend
himself and as a result that cost them
six years of incarceration
he went in as a you know I think a 19 20
year old dude and came out 25-26 after
doing State Prison time
um and the state product no one told but
the state prosecuted him because off the
medical records and you know they had
enough evidence but no one testified and
um
and so I write this I you know I go
through this recovery process and like I
went from
I want to kill this kid to like [ __ ] I
feel really bad for him I feel a lot of
compassion for what I did for him
and so I'm ready to make this amend and
um and I got this place of forgiveness
with him and ownership of my side of the
street I don't know where he is and um
and you know a lot of people live on the
street we don't have big
social profiles like you know what I
mean we're hard to find intentionally
and so my friend dies
and I go to the funeral I go the wake or
whatever it was and then I go to the
after thing and it's a big bonfire and
it's at night and I walk up to this fire
and I I sneak between two people it's
like shadowy you can't really see and
you know and I look to my right and it's
him wow and I'm like and he looks at me
and I look at him and we're both
like this
hey yo can I talk to you I put my hands
on body language
yes yeah we can talk and I walk off and
I make my Approach
he says you know
I appreciate that and I was wrong too
and me and them shake hands as men and
um and you know one last thing to worry
about on the street and we're all good I
think the funny thing about the immense
process and the spiritual journey the
path is like it places you in positions
that you can't see you just have to
blindly do the work and have the faith
and and like you know you don't know
I got this cat working for me he moves
from Maryland to take a job for me
there's a city it's like a top 10 worst
city in the country I used to run I grew
up right outside it's called Lawrence
Massachusetts it's like a drug heaven
like gangs it's bad I spent a lot of
time there and I'm telling them about it
on like a Sunday afternoon I'm like yeah
he's like bro let's go for a ride they
got good Spanish food down there so we
went down to the hood and I'm driving
around the hood just telling stories
with this guy that I'm friends with that
took a job for me and I'm driving down
Broadway
years later
and I see him and he's walking with some
prostitute and he's about 50 pounds
underweight he's strung out on drugs
and I'm like holy [ __ ] and I bust a huey
in the middle of the street I roll up on
him I'm like bro I jump out of the truck
he just puts his head down
and I'm like what's going on and he
spills beans he's like yeah little
[ __ ] up I'm living on the street I
can't stop shooting dope smoke crack
[ __ ] hooker [ __ ] girlfriend you know
like come on yeah it's a mess and I'm
like get it
and uh
you know we were able to get him to
treatment we were able to get him to
recovery and placed me in a position to
be useful to him and uh he's sober today
he's in recovery yeah he's living a good
life yeah yeah when you think of this
process like that story you just told
what immediately jumps to mind for me is
um Delante West I don't know if this is
a uh NBA player former NBA player who
um on multiple occasions because he's
former NBA players so people know who he
is uh who are into sports or whatever
and um uh if I remember correctly
there's a photo a couple years ago that
went super viral online uh because he
was at a red light begging for money
and uh people were like whoa
Fall From Grace right you go from
playing the NBA to now you know you're
on the street and uh there's a whole
bunch of people who tried to help I
think even uh there's a story Mark Cuban
like got in his car or something and I
went and found him like God hey we'll
help you you know we use the mass
facility whatever we got we you know
it's got billions of dollars like yeah
we will do what is necessary every
resource available
they sent him to a treatment center and
there was like some photos that came out
he was like riding horses I mean like
the the full-blown probably fifty
thousand dollar a year you know uh we're
gonna get you you're gonna get you well
a couple months later photos again he's
back on the street yeah and so I think
about like
your friend who you saw on the street
you were able to get him sober
doesn't sound like you sent him to a 50
000 a year facility doesn't sound like
you know he was going viral on the
internet any of this stuff
in that situation it seems like somebody
like a Mark Cuban did everything he
possibly could you couldn't ask somebody
to do more right what do you think is
the difference as to why one person ends
up being sober and the other one doesn't
is it just something that they have to
want it or is there something else I
mean they have to want it
um they have to do the work but they
also have to be given the proper
guidance and direction of what work to
do
um and so you know it really is
situational them have to want it is huge
you know drag the horse to water type of
thing
but what's interesting in that is
people in recovery
can speak to people with this condition
in a manner a language of the heart that
nobody else can like I've been here I've
been through that I'm on the other side
of it and it's really meaningful
um you know in a broader context I I
like to tell people that
your pain your trauma we all go through
it we're all living a human experience
we all got something that hurts right
and um and maybe that's a gift you know
whatever you've been through uniquely
qualifies you to help people that go
through that
um
but what you know one of the things
that's interesting to tie in the
business aspect to this about now the
addiction treatment center business
starts to Boom off of the Affordable
Health Care Act private Equity companies
and groups and financial institutions
start to flood in and and you know they
get slaughtered on their first round and
more in the modern day they're they're
smarter money but the next Frontier that
that private Equity groups have to
figure out in order to be successful in
this business
is is that
and what I mean by that and I've had
management meetings I've met with plenty
of groups and I'm like listen until you
guys in your suits in your Harvard mbas
until you guys figure out that that kid
with a criminal record and a face tattoo
who's an employee
is one of the most important people in
this facility
you're gonna [ __ ] this business up over
and over and over again because what
they're doing is they're coming in you
look at what they do they they buy
veterinary clinics dentists
um you know these different Healthcare
urgent care clinics and they consolidate
and they systemize and they kpi them to
death and they sterilize the business
and everything is process driven and
blah blah blah this is a business that
must include the language of the heart
and it's like a different
those guys don't do a good job all the
time some do but really understanding
that piece of it that you know when you
buy a Veterinary Clinic you don't need a
dog to help dogs you know what I mean
yeah and you don't have to be a tooth to
be a dentist but in this like you need
people in recovery you have to have that
language of the heart and so it's a lot
of the trouble that the financial
markets the private Equity groups are
having and figuring it out about this
business and how to scale and
consolidate you know also it sounds like
maybe your star employed doesn't look
like your star employee in some of these
other businesses that's what I mean
right and so they come in and they see
that guy as a threat and they see this
one that has a degree and a master's
degree and is a therapist they're like
oh star employee bad that guy has
criminal record and purple hair
you know and they they start to do what
they do in other businesses and they
sterilize them and um you know what the
patient facing and the people that are
actually going to help the people that
go in there
um you know it takes an arm it takes a
village but those people are incredibly
powerful and you need them yeah if
somebody's watching this right now and
they're addicted to any substance what
is like the one or two things that you
think is important for them to hear
that
here's the promise of recovery that you
never have to use drugs or alcohol again
foreign
but what's even more meaningful is you
never have to want to
and so that you can absolutely live a
life of freedom freedom from the
obsession of drinking drug and freedom
from the pain of what sobriety is if
you're willing and able to do the work
um you know that that is absolutely
possible for you and that if you can do
the work that you have no I mean bro I
got sober when 16 years ago on the run
for armed robbery amongst a bunch of
other crap a [ __ ] degenerate that
didn't have a single friend in the world
I had no idea my life was ending up like
this one foot in front of the other do
the work persevere and you just have no
idea how God's Gonna use you and what
this thing's going to look like yeah
it's um it's powerful right you have the
experience and and I think part of uh
what is true of most businesses is the
founder
they have to care that they have to
understand right they they see the
problem they feel the problem they know
how to solve the problem uh and many
times you know all the like [ __ ] uh
uh mantras online or whatever you know
solve your problem or whatever what is
so unique about your story is that your
problem yeah a lot of other people had
it but every single one of those people
have their own story they have their own
experience they have their specific
thing that is going to be the
Breakthrough right how many times did
somebody try to help you before you
wanted to do it before you found the
thing that worked for you like it's such
a unique thing it's not like hey
everyone needs a you know [ __ ] piece
of software to do excel right okay got
it it counts this is a much more
personal emotional thing and uh while
that is more challenging it's also much
more valuable when you figure it out as
you guys did which I think you know
people kind of
um It's A Hard business it seems like
right but uh uh they can be very
valuable when you figure it out
I agree it's a labor of love yeah where
can we send people to find you online if
they want to learn more uh Instagram is
the best place at Eric Spofford
um find me there
listen thank you so much for doing this
appreciate it we definitely want to do
it again in the future as you go build
the business all over again that's it
crazy